♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
JOE BIDEN: We're ending
America's longest war.
SPEAKER: Twenty years.
It's obviously not a success.
We knew we were there
to evacuate the at-risk Afghans.
You know, the US citizens.
SPEAKER 2: They kinda
made it sound like, "Oh,
it's gonna be quick and simple.
We're gonna be in and out."
(DISTANT EXPLOSION)
But that didn't happen here.
SOLDIER: You need to back up.
(CROWD CLAMORING)
Push back!
SPEAKER 3: It was very
dark times in Afghanistan,
when Taliban take over.
SPEAKER 4: I was told
that if you do not leave
in the coming three days,
you will be assassinated.
We've got thousands of people,
panicked.
SPEAKER 5:
The runway was the mission.
Keep the runway open
at all costs.
(SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE)
The government had collapsed.
The Afghan president was gone.
I'm being told, "Hey, we're
working with the Taliban now."
(SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE)
Our mission was to not let
anyone to leave the country.
SPEAKER 6: The situation
on the ground
is something like I've never
experienced before.
In any of my deployments.
Everyone was moving
toward the airport.
(SPEAKING IN FOREIGN LANGUAGE)
You never want to tell your men
you don't know what to do.
(SCATTERED YELLING)
Push back!
SPEAKER 7:
I had no idea what to do.
SPEAKER 2: Please, let us,
like, just get out of here.
(SCREAMING)
You leave a place where
you never think you'll leave.
(PEOPLE YELLING)
But you leave it
because you can't live.